dulces
y soy soy francisco
y soy un gps
y obviamente no me refiero un
geolocalizador verdad me refiero a que
soy gordo por siempre
y es que una vez que ha sido gordo pero
gordo gordo gordo lo vas a hacer siempre
y déjenme explico no me refiero a esos
que tienen una rutina de ejercicios muy
bien elaborada una dieta perfectamente
estructurada y un físico envidiable que
el día que rompen la dieta o no van al
gimnasio se ven frente al espejo se
levantan la blue citizen
no no no
yo me refiero a los cursos gordos cortos
de adeveras a esos que cuando los
diputados en san lázaro prohibieron el
uso ya sabes de elefantes osos bueno
animales en general en los circos y lo
que nos alegró no fue precisamente que
los animales dejarán de sufrir digo qué
bueno que dejaron de sufrir no está bien
gacho como sufrían lo que verdaderamente
nos alegró
fue que teníamos la guerra contra el
bullying a nada hoy ya sabes no way ya
tuviste has hecho un cerdo puede ver
asiste al circo que momento que ya no se
aceptan animales son los circos por lo
tanto me toleras en casa y te fregaste
teníamos la guerra ganada güey es lo que
verdaderamente festejábamos
el que ya estaba prohibido el uso de los
animales y podíamos defendernos y con la
mano en la cintura donde debería de ir
podíamos vitorear nos de ello ese tipo
de gordos me refiero
y eso sí algo tenía que tener digo o
eres guapo o eres rico o eres
inteligente o de perdido tienes bonita
letra o
pero si no eres guapo no eres rico no
eres inteligente y tu letra estada en
adobe salvo hay que buscarle y eso sí mi
talento baila
creo que todavía sigue y cuando llegaba
al antro se hacía un círculo alrededor
mío y no tanto porque me quisieran ver
bailar sino porque sabían que si no se
hacían al lado iban a ser atropellados
por mis movimientos de cadera
entonces preferían hacerse a un lado
y ese ese soy yo
cuando mi papá murió yo tenía tan solo 6
años
tiempo atrás le diagnosticaron cáncer y
fue un suceso sumamente complicado para
toda la familia
a la par la persona que se suponía que
tenía que hacer y cuidar de mí
abusaba sexualmente
y eso de protestos o totalmente mi
autoestima y lo único que podía ser un
individuo en esta situación o por lo
menos lo único que pude hacer en esta
situación fue comer
pero es que la depresión jamás se fue a
los 14 años ya la talla 36 a los 34 y la
talla 46
la depresión no se iba
fingía y fingía ser feliz
y cuando llegaba el doctor y me decía
por favor adelgaza en más no me decía me
rogaba imploraba su pareja de rodillas y
me decía güey adelgaza webb los
triglicéridos están hasta el tope tu
colesterol está a punto de matarte
adelgaza está viendo voy a adelgazar un
poco
damas mientras los resultados médicos
pudieran decir que ya estaba de este
lado y no del otro
pero volvía a recaer
y volvía a pasar porque no había una
verdadera motivación y más porque
insisto siempre dije si me quieren y así
me quieran
si me quiero ver un gordito simpático
madre buena onda para qué quieres que
cambie un chip que es el ponerse a dieta
pero la realidad es otra
la realidad era y la realidad es que la
confianza en mí mismo
en la seguridad en mí mismo no existía
se había ido hace muchos años
era más fácil decir casi me acepten a
aceptar y yo no me querían y confiar en
mí
que no creía que era capaz de provocar
un cambio en mi vida que no creía que
era capaz de que las cosas mejoraron
la vida y los sucesos se habían
encargado
de decirme que yo no valía la pena
la vida y los sucesos me habían dicho
que lo que era lo que era
y encontrar la motivación está cañón
no es sencillo
pero qué hacer cuando ya todo estaba
totalmente gris cuando ya estaba en el
hoyo si se podía estar más ig
bueno
lo que quiero y quiero con mi vida
es lo que va a pasar con ella
y lo primero pues descubrir es lo que
quería
y descubrir que me encantaba viajar
conocer muchos lugares conocer mucha
gente descubrir otras formas de vida y
no ver las noticias que siempre son
amarillistas sino ver a las personas que
realmente te llenan
valió me acogí
y pos total de rayito a ver como viaje
pero yo ya tenía claro qué es lo que
quería
amaba viajar
y amaba hablar
a ver cómo lo hacemos y si muy contento
y después de todo un trayecto de no sé
cuántas horas en carretera hablando
conmigo mismo
dije definitivamente lo que voy a hacer
es viajar y platicar y que la gente me
escuche
eso es lo que voy a hacer estoy seguro
que siempre lo quise
pero nunca lo creí posible
cuando comencé a creer que aquello que
soñaba que aquello que anhelaba era
posible y entonces las cosas fueron
sucediendo
y no es sencillo creer
no es sencillo creer en ti mismo
no es sencillo creer que tú puedes
porque tú ni un niño interno te ha dicho
y no vale la pena
porque tu niño interno y tu historia de
vida te dice que no es posible ser
diferente
origen o la madre way sí es posible hoy
ya tantos que se han podido tengo que
creer
y levantarme todas las mañanas como un
alcohólico en recuperación y decir
solo por hoy
y creer que era posible
solo por hoy voy a creer en mí
solo por hoy voy a creer que mis sueños
son posibles
solo por hoy voy a creer que soy capaz
y mañana quién sabe
pero hoy creo en mí
y comencé a viajar
y en nuestros viajes tuve la oportunidad
de conocer a mucha gente interesante
sumamente interesante
entre ellos los ancianos aunque ahorita
los relegamos están llenos de sabiduría
y uno de ellos perteneciente a la
cultura maya
platicando le dije que fue lo que
hicieron los mayas y los aztecas los
griegos y los hombres que a través de la
historia y a través del espacio y a
través del tiempo han logrado trascender
muy sabio levanta su mirada en un ritual
muy complicado
no todos lo saben pero hoy lo voy a
compartir contigo
tengo el secreto mágico el secreto
ancestral y va a ser conmigo
me lo dijo
y hoy quiero compartirlo con ustedes
y quiero que cuando estén en su casa que
cuando inicien su día y que cuando
despierten todos los días tengan
claridad en lo que sueñan crean que es
posible y sobre todo hagan este ritual
en cuanto abran los ojos vas a comenzar
a mover tus mano derecha la moverás con
fuerza permitiendo que la energía del
universo se haga presente en tu mano
derecha
después respira respiras profundo y
moverás la mano izquierda permitiendo
que el universo cargue de energía a tus
dos manos y si es posible mueve tus pies
mueve los 29 los completamente y
moviendo tu mano derecha a tu mano
izquierda tu pie derecho tu pie izkierdo
tu cadera tu cabeza todo tu cuerpo
repite estas palabras pero más que
repetir las alas las vidas
baja no hay de otra vez a mover la mano
derecha a mover la mano izquierda a
mover los piecitos a mover la mente y a
trabajar duro no hay de otra
o trabajas o trabajas
si tienes claridad en tus sueños si tres
es posible
y trabajas de manera dura
todo es posible
y aquí viene el cuarto punto que es
esencial y básico
celebra
si no celebras lo que has avanzado qué
caso tiene que lo hayas hecho y celebra
comparando te con el yo de la mañana
llega en la noche y revisa qué fue lo
que hiciste si yo hoy me comparar a
con los triatletas con los super físicos
y todo dijera la madre qué fregados
estás
pero me comparo con el paco con él
francisco con el pancho con el ico que
despertó por la mañana
y dio
avanzas t
avanzas te tragaste un pliego pero no
comiste postre avanzaste
celebra lo
no importa cuán poco sea lo que avanzas
te
celebrarlo por la noche porque eso te
permitirá ir a la cama dormir y
despertar diciendo
felices 24
muchas gracias y sean felices
[Aplausos]